>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS ARE IN A FULL
PANIC, THEIR SOCIALIST POLICIES
ARE A DISASTER.
THEIR POLL NUMBERS ARE
IMPLODING, THEIR PRESIDENT IS A
DISHONEST, CORRUPT, AND
COGNITIVE WRECK IN THEIR WAR ON
FREE SPEECH IS NOW BEING
CHALLENGED IN A HUGE WAY BY
ELON MUSK WHO IS ATTEMPTING TO
TAKE OVER THEIR FAVORITE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM, THAT IS
TWITTER.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THAT
LATER IN THE PROGRAM, BUT FIRST
WE ARE AT THE BEGINNING OF WHAT
IS ANOTHER LONG WEEKEND AWAY
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE FOR THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD.
TODAY, BEFORE JETTING OFF TO
CAMP DAVID, JOE BIDEN TOOK SOME
TIME TO BLAME THE WAR IN UKRAINE
AND ALL OF HIS FAILURES ON
SOMEBODY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: PUTIN'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE HAS DRIVEN
UP GAS PRICES ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
UKRAINE AND RUSSIA ARE THE ONE
AND TWO LARGEST PRODUCERS IN THE
WORLD.
WE ARE NUMBER THREE.
SHUT DOWN.
WE SAW THAT YESTERDAY'S
INFLATION DATA.
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IS THAT
70% OF THE INCREASE IN INFLATION
WAS A CONSEQUENCE OF HIS PRICE
HIKE BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT ON
OIL PRICES.
70%.
WE NEED -- WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THESE HIGH PRICES, AND URGENTLY.
FOR WORKING FOLKS OUT THERE.
>> Sean: ALL OF THAT IS A
COMPLETE AND UTTER LIE.
WHO IS HE SHAKING HANDS WITH?
SHAKE -- THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
WE ARE NEARLY 15 MONTHS INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY.
EVERYTHING IS GOING WRONG, AND I
MEAN EVERYTHING.
I CAN'T NAME A SINGLE THING
THAT'S GOING RIGHT.
BY THE WAY, ANYBODY SURPRISED,
BIDEN CANNOT EVEN DO SIMPLE
FUNDAMENTAL BASIC TASKS.
HE TURNS AROUND -- NOBODY THERE
TO SHAKE HIS HAND AND HE KEEPS
HIS HAND OUT THERE.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
MEANWHILE, INFLATION AT A 40
YEAR HIGH AND GETTING HIGHER.
FOOD COSTS, THE COST OF EVERY
ITEM YOU BUY IN EVERY STORE IS
NOW GOING THROUGH THE ROOF.
ENERGY COSTS.
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN PAID MORE IN
HISTORY FOR A GALLON OF GASOLINE
AND THE COST TO HEAT AND COOL
YOUR HOME IS THROUGH THE ROOF.
ON TOP OF THAT, RENTS HAVE NOW
INCREASED BY OVER 17%.
INTEREST RATES I READ TODAY IT'S
ABOUT 5% FOR A 30-YEAR FIXED.
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO YOU WERE
GETTING IT IN THE 2s.
THEY ARE RISING FAST.
THE WAGES ARE DOWN BY 3% AND
BIDEN'S GREEN NEW DEAL ECONOMY
IS NOW A LIVING NIGHTMARE FOR
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, FOR
ALL OF US.
BUT REMEMBER, ACCORDING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION, AMERICA'S
HISTORIC INFLATION HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH BIDEN'S TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN NEW HANDOUTS AND THE
RECORD-SETTING ENERGY COSTS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH BIDEN'S
RESTRICTIONS ON OIL AND GAS.
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT FROM THE
CHARTS, WE WILL KEEP PUTTING
THEM UP AND DOWN, UP IS DOWN,
DOWN IS UP IN THEIR WEIRD WORLD.
AND BY THE WAY, EVERYTHING BAD
THAT HAPPENS IS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
FAULT AND AS THOSE GRAPHS SHOW,
THAT IS A LIE.
AND THANKFULLY, AMERICANS CAN
SEE THROUGH THE TOTAL, WELL,
BULL-SCHIFF, AS IN ADAM SCHIFF.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TRYING TO
LABEL THIS PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE
BUT MOST AMERICANS ACCORDING TO
A NEWS POLL ARE NOT BUYING THAT,
ONLY 6% BLAME PUTIN, MOST
BELIEVE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POLICIES ARE VERY MUCH TO BLAME.
>> Sean: KNEW PAUL FROM
QUINNIPIAC THAT JUST CAME OUT
YESTERDAY, BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING AT AN ALL-TIME LOW.
LOOK AT THIS, 33%.
THAT'S IT.
HIS APPROVAL AMONG
HISPANIC AMERICANS IS EVEN
LOWER.
26%.
BIDEN IS UNDERWATER BY DOUBLE
DIGITS IN FIVE RECENT POLLS,
AMERICANS AREN'T JUST UNHAPPY
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, THEY ALSO
DISAPPROVE ABOUT -- OF BIDEN'S
HANDLING OF UKRAINE, CRIME,
COVID, AND OF COURSE THE
DISASTER OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
NEVER MIND THE DISASTROUS PULL
OUT IN THE ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF
AFGHANISTAN WHERE HE ABANDONED
AMERICANS, FELLOW GREEN CARD
HOLDERS, ILLEGALLY ELIGIBLE TO
BE HERE, LEFT BILLIONS IN
HIGH-TECH MILITARY EQUIPMENT,
SOME $80 BILLION WORTH, ABANDON
OUR AFGHAN ALLIES.
TONIGHT AS BIDEN EXTENDS THE
MASK MANDATES ON AMERICANS
TRAVELING ON TRAINS AND PLANES,
GUESS WHAT?
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT.
HE'S LIFTING ALL COVID
RESTRICTIONS ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE POURING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
ISN'T THAT GREAT?
MAY 23RD, TITLE 42 WILL BE
LIFTED, PREVENTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM EXPELLING
MIGRANTS OVER COVID-19 CONCERNS,
AND THAT MEANS MORE MASSIVE
MIGRANT CARAVANS, THEY ARE ON
THE WAY.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
BIDEN IS MAKING A HUGE MISTAKE,
AND FOR GOOD REASON, BECAUSE
RIGHT ON CUE, THE FIRST OF WHAT
WILL BE MANY CARAVANS IS ONLY
DAYS AWAY.
THIS PROBLEM AT THE BORDER IS SO
BAD AND ABOUT TO GET SO MUCH
WORSE.
IN FACT, BORDER OFFICIALS ARE
NOW BRACING FOR MORE THAN A HALF
A MILLION MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS
NEXT MONTH ALONE.
INSTEAD OF FIXING THE PROBLEM,
REINSTATING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SUCCESSFUL BORDER POLICIES,
BUILDING THE WALL, BRINGING BACK
"REMAIN IN MEXICO" POLICY,
ENDING CATCH AND PROCESS AND
RELEASE, WELL, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE NOW
CONSIDERING A PLAN TO TAKE VA
DOCTORS OUT OF VA HOSPITALS SO
THOSE VA DOCTORS FOR OUR VETS
CAN ASSIST WITH THE ONGOING
CRISIS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WILL TAKE
AWAY DOCTORS FROM OUR VA
HOSPITALS, FROM AMERICAN
VETERANS, TO PROVIDE THEIR
SERVICES TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
DOES THAT SIT RIGHT WITH YOU?
BECAUSE THAT DOES NOT SIT RIGHT
WITH ME.
BIDEN AND THE FAR LEFT CLIMATE
SOCIALIST AROUND HIM ARE
LITERALLY DESTROYING THE COUNTRY
RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
IT IS SO BAD EVEN LATE-NIGHT
LIBERAL HOST BILL MAHER HAS
ISSUED THIS MORNING.
THEY WON'T HEAT IT, BUT THEY
SHOULD, TO HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
>> THERE IS A HUNGER FOR, I
THINK, IN AMERICA MORE THAN
ANYTHING IS COMMON SENSE THAT
AWAY FROM THE EXTREMES -- WHEN
PEOPLE SAY TO ME, YOU KNOW,
DON'T YOU THINK YOU'VE GOT MORE
CONSERVATIVE?
NO, I HAVEN'T.
THE LEFT HAS GOTTEN GOOFIER.
SO I SEEM MORE CONSERVATIVE
MAYBE, BUT IT'S NOT ME WHO
CHANGED.
I FEEL I'M THE SAME GUY.
I AM ALWAYS SAYING TO THE
DEMOCRATS, JUST DON'T BE THE
PARTY OF NO COMMON SENSE AND YOU
WILL BE SURPRISED AT HOW MUCH
AMAZING SUCCESS YOU WILL HAVE AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, WHICH IS THERE GOING TO
GET KICKED IN NOVEMBER.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, I FINALLY
AGREE WITH BILL MAHER, AND I
WOULD AGREE WITH HIS ASSESSMENT.
HE'S NOT REALLY CHANGED.
HE'S NEVER LIKED ME, I'VE NEVER
PARTICULARLY LIKED HIM, BUT HE'S
PRETTY SMART, INTELLIGENT,
DEMOCRATS WOULD BE WISE TO
LISTEN TO HIM.
MANY OF HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
COMMON SENSE IS DEAD IN THIS NEW
GREEN DEAL CLIMATE ALARMIST
RELIGIOUS CULT DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY'VE GONE NUTS, THE LIBERALS
IN THE PARTY HAVE BEEN REPLACED
WITH BARLETT SOCIALIST THAT
DON'T BELIEVE IN FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
THEY BELIEVE AND CANCEL CULTURE.
THEY BELIEVE IN WOKE EVERYTHING.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BELIEVE IN
CAPITALISM OR A CONSTITUTION
EITHER.
THEY JUST WORSHIP ALL THINGS AT
THE ALTAR OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THEY WANT TO FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY INTO
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
SEVEN MONTHS FROM NOW DURING THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, IT IS
IMPERATIVE TO TAKE NOTHING FOR
GRANTED, GET TO THE POLLS, SEND